dernière répétition de Platée de rameaux
joués à l'Opéra Royal de Versailles dans
ce théâtre tant voulu par Louis XIV
s'enchaîne des spectacles tout au long
de l'année ce petit chef-d'oeuvre
d'astuces et de grâce fait tout en bois
ne perçoit aucune subvention c'est
financements l'Opéra royal les tient des
recettes d'entrée mais surtout des
mécènes le cercle de l'Opéra c'est donc
son nom regroupe 12 mécènes le cercle
existe depuis 2009 il vient de s'ouvrir
au PME et au TPE aux toutes petites
entreprises c'est la possibilité de
faire des choses qu'on aurait peut-être
pas pu faire alors ça peut être acheté
un clavecin dont on a besoin pour
l'opéra ça peut être financé un
spectacle qu'on n'aurait pas pu financer
cette année parce qu'on en aurait pas eu
les moyens tout seul le ticket d'entrée
pour intégrer le cercle des mécènes est
fixé à 4000 euros et peut atteindre
45000 euros mais parler d'argent dans ce
domaine c'est toujours disons déplacé il
est un intérêt fiscal mais enfin c'est
pas l'intérêt majeur les majeur c'est
quand même de participer à ce que notre
patrimoine vive et vivent bien le retour
il se fait en comment dirais-je en
ambiance en contact en richesse de
contact et puis quand on est amoureux on
compte pas comme on dit donc
ne parlons pas de
d'avantage fiscal c'est c'est
la street fulgate quoi grâce à l'argent
des mécènes l'Opéra Royal de Versailles
a pu s'offrir une création de Denis
Podalydès d'autres événements seront
proposés à l'occasion de l'année le
nôtre qui va occuper la vie du château
pendant tout 2013